hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter nine
of his monologue Jim and so first
introduces us to an idea that many
people are going to find either
difficult to grasp or difficult to
accept even provisionally to say that
handsome himself could hold this idea
because it is quite foreign to the way
that many people will think about things
it is a common way for at least you know
neoplatonism in this case Christian
plainest to to make sense of things to
think about how ideas and God and
created things all fit in together so
what we're talking about here is the
pre-existence or if you like the the
greater existence of all things within
the divine reason or word and the term
that Anselm is using in chapter 9 is
reason roxio a little bit later in
chapter 10 he is going to talk in terms
of word or expression of a cut CO and
then further on it's going to be word
fear of them it's important to know that
it would make
to go between these terms because you
know within a Christian perspective you
know in the Gospels where you know
particularly the Gospel of John or its
talked about as the word right not
simply the word is in what's written or
said but the you know the second person
of the Trinity as being the word or
Jesus Christ as being the word that term
logos in Greek does conveyed both reason
and word so this is something that an
some although he's not reading Greek
would certainly know about that and so
there's a bit of you might say
linguistic play there that we're not
quite so receptive to now Ansem is going
to assert that he's just talking about
how all things are created from nothing
and then he says well they're not
completely from nothing they are created
from nothing in the sense that they're
not created from a thing but they are
not nothing before they're created
before their may so that sounds a little
paradoxical wait aren't they coming from
nothing well how would you know to bring
this thing into being or that thing into
being before you know things are created
if they're totally all nothing then you
can't distinguish one thing from another
thing because he had nothing there are
no distinctions right you just have
nothing and you don't even have like one
big mess that you can look in it's just
nothing there's nothing there so they do
exist somewhere according to an some
things he says exist within the reason
of their maker in some sense before they
are made so I want to make a boy I you
know can think of the shape of book and
the function and you know there's all
sorts of qualities or characteristics
that can go in
I have an idea in my head so it in
Psalms view what happens in creation in
things being made in you know things
being brought into being from nothing is
that the Creator is God the Supreme
Being actually has some idea of what it
is that here it or whatever is going to
make exist whatever it is he's going to
bring into being now the question is
what is that right and that's where it's
going to get quite interesting and
someone's going to use an example here
to try to not to say that it's exactly
like this but to try to help us grasp it
he says there's no way anyone can make
something unless something like a
pattern or to put it more suitably a
form or like this or rule of the thing
to be made already existed in the reason
of the maker no not just in you know
some book somewhere but the maker he has
to actually know what he or she is is do
it suppose especially if they're making
it out nothing you know if you at least
have a pattern to work with you're
making it from something so he says it's
clear that what these things were going
to be and what sorts of things and how
they were going to be notice all those
characteristics very important let's
read that again what's what they were
going to be what the things themselves
are in the mind of the maker what
they're going to be once they're created
what sorts of things what genre what
type do they fit into how they are going
to be what qualities what attributes
what even relations are they going to
head with each other was in the reason
of the Supreme nature now notice what he
says before all things were made so from
before creation itself according to an
so
things that haven't yet gone into
existence out here exists in the mind of
the Divine Being who will bring them
into being according to that pattern now
he goes on will fit and he says it's
clear the things that were made were
nothing before they were made in the
sense that they were not with the air
now and there was not anything from
which they were made so so being made
from nothing has now been rather
qualified right says they were not
nothing with respect to the reason of
their maker God knew what it was that
God was going to create before anything
was created and that existence now in
God's mind is what we want to think
about let's look now at chapter 11 where
he says there is there's actually a big
dissimilarity between how we think of
the human artisan or maker creating
something and how the divine being
presumably does so he says I see much
dissimilarity in this comparison the
supreme substance collected nothing at
all from any other source which he would
either assemble within himself the form
of the things he was going to make or
bring it about that the things
themselves exist so God doesn't need any
sort of guide books or external you know
you know patterns or anything like that
gallery has that within the divine mind
with the reason the word as we're going
to see so the craftsman by contrast
cannot even imagine a physical object
and thus conceded in his mind unless
he's already come to know the object
either as a whole all at once or part by
part through various things nor that's
one big difference right in order for us
to think about something now we can say
well we can imagine something that
doesn't yet exist sure but what you're
doing is is a process of
zishan of ideas that you had to get from
somewhere you had to acquire the ideas
if you want to call it even knowledge
that you are using in order to make
things down to even you know placing
letter is on the board I can only do
that because when I was a little boy you
know why me I don't even remember how it
happened all I remember is not liking
write in cursive they made us write lots
of letters I remember that lined paper
vaguely and I acquired the ideas that
allow me to make this right God doesn't
have to do that God already has all of
the ideas according to Ansel so that's
one important distinction what else what
a human crashed person like he says he
can't complete the work he's conceived
in his mind if he lacks either the
material or something without which the
plan work cannot be made so a man can
invent an animal the likes of which
never existed by thinking it or painting
it but he can only do this by putting
together parts stored in his memory from
things that he knew at another time and
it's not like he can actually create a
new animal out of you know bits and
pieces and we might say oh well what
about Jurassic Park willing and you know
that's a fiction right you know we can
do things but notice how much you know a
knowledge acquisition is involved in
that and how many tools we have to have
the Divine Being doesn't need that it
just pops everything into creation
according to this pattern or rule or
whatever you want to call it that it
already has and the divine reason so
there is a dissimilarity there discussed
in chapter 11 another very important
point it is discussed in chapter 31 the
title of chapter 31 is the this word is
not a likeness of created things but the
truth of their essence or the truth of
their beating whereas creative things
are an imitation of that truth and then
which
nature's are greater more excellent in
others which is why we discuss this in
talking about the hierarchy or degrees
of being in a previous video here what
we're looking at is the relationship
between the beings that exist in created
reality and how they are in the divine
work in some goes so far as to say that
those patterns or likenesses are in a
certain sense more true more real in God
than they are in us so let's let's
actually spell out what they would he
and concretely not only is it the case
that say dad has a you know more real
notion of get rid of some of my ass
track at this point of chalk you know of
these particular kinds of being and what
kind of being they are what type truck
God does the same thing for complex
creatures at a very high level of being
like myself a rational being or you who
are watching this and understanding in a
certain sense if Ansel is correct this
is where many people may say I can't
accept that in a certain sense of Ansel
is correct the me who exists in God's
mind and the divine reason or the Divine
Word is more real is more me than what I
am here in front of you let alone the
image that you yourself are seeing on
here the image is less real than me
right do you have access to me through
the image I according to an some would
be less real than I Greg sammler
existing in the divine mine why because
the divine being exists more than
anything else does he says it's not a
sum as if there's a lightness of create
things in the Divine Word or reason
that's a mix-up that's a you know you
might say backwards prioritization of
the relationship between original and
copy the original lies in the divine
mind and all the created things are
merely imitations and not particularly
good imitations of that essence of that
being so you know we go all the way from
things not being nothing existing in the
divine mind to them being truly
something even more some things than the
beings once they have been been brought
into being through creation